good evening everyone how is everyone
doing today I bow before you I have a
segment of my channel that I've done
twice before called stuckman suggest and
it's a way that I can kind of bring
light to channels that I really like
some channels I like to watch and people
that I think are really cool and then I
hope you guys like - a lot of times
people ask me like you know Chris what
are the channels do you like to watch
would you enjoy watching on YouTube who
are some of the people you really think
are deserving of attention and really
think are pretty cool so you guys can
kind of get a better idea of who I am as
a person and also hopefully find some
channels that you can find some
enjoyment in the past the two segments I
did were all females this one's a
sausagefest so have fun with me as I
talk about a lot of dudes first off I'd
like to tell you guys about Anders
Watsky this guy is freaking awesome
seriously this is one of the coolest
YouTube reviewers out there and I have
no idea why he doesn't have more
subscriptions he deserves so many more
than he does
he lives in Australia which
automatically makes him more manly than
me whenever he makes a video I get so
excited because his reviews are so
entertaining take a look at this clip
from his Mission Impossible 4 review
well I haven't seen the TV series the
first Mission Impossible movie played it
straight slick and smart although it
hasn't particularly aged well given how
cutting-edge all the technology is
central now I'm telling you nobody runs
quite as fast as Tom Cruise does on
screen I'm talking housewife to an IKEA
sale fast and it's that kind of
intensity and dedication to his
performance that really sells the action
cuz your reviews can look pristine and
excellent quality and everything but if
you're not likeable
there's no point and anders is so funny
he's such a likeable guy take a look at
this other video he did he does videos
not just reviews but like interesting
commentary on film in general and kind
of the Hollywood community and
everything take a look this video he did
about trailers and how to make the
cliched awesome trailer that we keep
seeing that sound which is being in like
every movie trailer for the last three
years is what I like to call the angry
boat so angry and it's not hard to see
why they keep using this sound it's just
epic
Andrews videos are spectacular they're
fantastic he really deserves your
subscription he also writes for a
website called movie Dexcom and he is on
Rotten Tomatoes he's an accredited
Rotten Tomatoes critic which is also
pretty hardcore
Andrews you are awesome I love your
videos go check out Andrews videos
they're awesome he sees awesome the
second channel I'd like to tell you guys
about I just did like the thing isn't
this a thing the shows know are my
buddies and they started a second
channel called Schmo plus I'm inspired
by creativity I really really love
creativity and Christian started this TV
show called grasping at straws and it's
airing on the internet right now on that
channel it starts people who are now
stars like Serena Ben said from cabin
fever very attractive female just
letting you know you guys probably know
that she's in there and you can see here
on top of a guy bed and I'm just gonna
move on cuz I'm gonna start thinking
about that it's not a good idea the
Christian wrote these episodes himself
and they're actually very good I was I
was into them I I would have watched
that it was on TV I legitimately would
have watched that if it was on TV but
like I said I'm really inspired by
creativity I love making films I love
writing I would like to be a filmmaker
myself and so when I found out that they
were involved with trying to do that
themselves in the past that was really
inspiring to me and I love that I like
some of Christians lines in the episode
check this one out this one was on my
favorites
starwars I know he raped my childhood
and you raped my adult thank you pick
Harry's that's what I would say to a
girl if I was breaking up tore through I
feel like you know what I'd reference
some Dragon Ball Z thing or something
because that's just how nerdy I am
another thing I relate to by the show is
fat Ellis stars in it a few times yes
Mark Ellis used to be fat he's in the
show I used to be fat I relate to that I
just told you all that I used to be fat
scour the internet for pictures they're
not there don't worry there's there's
nothing you won't find anything I remove
them all okay guys the last channel I'd
like to talk to you guys about is a
sketch comedy channel that I when I
first the first episode aired I was like
I don't know about this but I gave it
some time and I got into it I honestly
did I like what these guys are doing
these two buddies of mine Benny and
Victor started this channel where they
do sketch comedy bits it's called kosher
coffee and they sit there and they
basically improv a lot of it they have
an idea of where they're going with each
episode but it's basically them just
sitting down trying to find strange
abstract humor in the strangest little
situations it's so strange
it really is strange but that's why I
like it it's so out there I love when
people aren't afraid to put themselves
out there and be really weird you know
what I mean I'm really inspired by that
because see so many people who are
sitting behind the camera and they're
afraid to be themselves there they're
afraid to talk the way they want to talk
they're trying to conform to the way
society thinks they should be or they're
just trying to be someone else these
guys are being themselves they're being
insanely funny silly people and I think
that's really cool I put links to all
three of these channels below I think
all of them are worth your time and
subscription and I want to also let you
guys know that pretty soon I'm going to
be reviewing the original Star Wars
trilogy I've wanted to do that for a
long time at the end of each review I'm
going to put a special skit in which I
take some time to film and put together
and I hope you guys enjoy it to look
forward to that guys I'll be back very
soon with some new reviews I'm seeing
the three stooges on Tuesday yeah
alright but if you like this you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes